[Music]  it's the so-called beautiful game but  far less beautiful as the murky world of  football tax fraud involving some of the  biggest names in the sport a recent leak  of over 18 million documents contains  serious allegations of corruption among  top officials clubs agents and players  as well as complex methods being used to  dodge the taxman a special parliamentary  inquiry committee first set up to  investigate the Panama papers leaks  involving offshore accounts is now  delving into the football leaks bodies  like FIFA and UEFA are in the hot seat  MEP s are questioning the opaque system  of transferring players for huge sums of  money how European clubs are financed  and earnings from players image rights  which it not tax as much as salaries  it's another step in the --use push to  tighten the noose on money laundering  and tax fraud  [Music]